la vie privée et l'anonymat bientôt des
concept archaïque c'est en tout cas ce
que fait craindre clé review une
entreprise américaine créée en 2017 qui
a collecté et identifiés plus de 10
milliards de photos pour alimenter un
gigantesque système de reconnaissance
faciale
comment ont-ils fait pour se constituer
une telle banque d'image et bien les
siphonnant sur google facebook ou encore
twitter
ces géants du net ont d'ailleurs mise en
demeure la start up américaine pour
qu'elle mette un terme à toute collecte
d'image sur leurs sites respectifs et
qu'elle supprime toutes celles qui ont
déjà été stocké le règlement de youtube
interdit explicitement de collecter des
données qu'ils puissent être utilisés
pour identifier une personne pour le
dirigeant de kerviel son entreprise a
agi en toute légalité
notre système est conçu pour ne prendre
que des informations disponibles
publiquement
d'accord mais quand on ouvre un compte
facebook ou instagram on ne signe pas
pour finir dans une banque de données
internationales vendus on sait qui est
encore moins pour être suivie dans tous
ses déplacements par des logiciels de
reconnaissance faciale d'ailleurs en
fait si on sait par qui on compte pas
moins de 2200 organismes publics et
privés à travers le monde à des
opérateurs télécoms des établissements
scolaires des banques ainsi que le fbi
et une centaine d'autres organisations
de maintien de l'ordre la technologie
aurait notamment largement servi aux
forces de l'ordre pour identifier les
personnes qui ont pénétré de force dans
le congrès américain le 6 janvier
dernier en belgique quand la police
serait effectuée entre sans une et 500
perquisition avec ce logiciel et avait
jusqu'ici toujours nié son utilisation
et pour cause la pratique et dans ce
pays tout bonnement inégale la
reconnaissance faciale est certes une
piste intéressante à utiliser sur le
long terme pour soutenir le
fonctionnement de la police mais cela
n'est bien entendu possible etc avec une
base légale correct afin que les
éléments obtenus puissent être utilisés
légalement administrativement et
judiciairement et en france c'est bien
que c'est évidemment tout aussi illégal
comme dans toute l'union européenne
ne serait-ce qu'en vertu du rgp dès le
règlement général sur la protection des
données il interdit formellement depuis
mai 2010huit toute utilisation des
données personnelles non consenti
pourtant une enquête de baisse chez news
qui dit avoir eu accès aux registres de
claix review recense quelques 400
connexion au système de personnel du
ministère de l'intérieur information
vigoureusement démenti place beauvau le
ministère de l'intérieur n'a aucune
information sur clear view l'ogre de la
reconnaissance faciale à la légalité
douteuse pourtant plus de 400 recherches
ont été effectuées par la police dans la
base de données outre sa légalité
douteuse la technologie clear view
semble avoir ses limites aux états unis
chez un noir américain a été arrêté à
tort en 2019 à cause de la
reconnaissance faciale robert williams
c'est son nom il a passé 30 heures en
détention parce qu'un logiciel avait
jugé identique la photo ne sont permis
de conduire et l'image floue d'un voleur
de montre comment expliquer à mes filles
qu'un ordinateur s'est trompé mais que
la police l'a quand même écouter il
semble donc urgent de mettre en place un
cadre légal clair uniforme et globale
pour anticiper certains scénarios de ce
type c'est ce que tente d'ailleurs de
faire le parlement européen l'instance
s'est prononcé mercredi en faveur d'un
rapport qui prône l'interdiction totale
de la surveillance biométriques de masse
3 177 voix contre
248 un premier pas car le texte adopté
n'a pas de force législative mais il
vise à inspirer la commission européenne
nous envoyons un message clair les
droits fondamentaux sont irrévocables
pour la toute première fois nous
appelons à un moratoire sur le
déploiement des systèmes de
reconnaissance faciale à des fins
répressives
ces technologies ayant démontré leur
inefficacité et souvent abouti à des
résultats discriminant en attendant la
reconnaissance faciale semble avoir de
beaux jours devant elle preuve en est
claire vient continu de développer son
outil à travers deux aspects le premier
celui de rendre plus net une image floue
en ayant recours à l'apprentissage
automatique pour tenter d'imaginer ce à
quoi elle pourrait ressembler la seconde
innovation repose aussi sur
l'imagination et tente de représenter le
visage d'une personne masquée elle
s'appuierait cette innovation sur un
modèle statistiques établies à partir de
données récoltées un scénario qu'on n'a
pas pu voir venir pas même dans les
pires films de science fiction